On the next flyer, there'll be a list of threats, and we're asking you to order these
by the seriousness of the threat.
For the question, assume Alice is communicating with Bob
using TOR and wants to keep this a secret.
Alice uses the TOR protocol to set up a circuit between onion router 1, 2 and 3,
and uses onion router 3 as the exit node to reach Bob.
Answer by listing the letters in order from the most severe threat to the least severe--
for example--dacbe, which is not the correct answer. We'll give you that one for free.
Do note that some of these are subjective and multiple
orderings may be considered correct.
And here are the six threats--the first one,
An attacker in the middle intercepts the Relay Extend request between onion router 2 and
onion router 3 and attempts to set up a different Diffie-Hellman key.
The second threat, a malicious attacker controls the directory server from which Alice learns
the identity keys of onion router 1, onion router 2, and onion router 3.
And the third threat, Alice's Onion Proxy is compromised.
And the fourth threat, an eavesdropping attacker can observe all network traffic.
And the fifth threat, onion router 1 and onion router 3 are both controlled by the same
malicious attacker who has no other access to the network.
And the final threat, onion router 1 and onion router 2 are both controlled by the same
Order these threats from the most severe to the least severe.